Once you've gained enough practice,
these reductions begin to
feel a little repetitive.
And it's natural to wonder whether
there is a theorem that would
capture them all.
Indeed there is, and it is
traditionally called Rice's Theorem,
after H.G Rice's 1953
paper on the subject.
This is a very powerful theorem,
and it implies that we can't say
anything about a computer just based
on the language that it recognizes.
So far the pattern has been that we've
wanted to show that some language L
was undecidable, and
this language L was about descriptions
of Turing machines whose languages,
that is the set of strings that they
accept, have a certain property.
Two things have to be
true about this language.
First, as we have said,
that the membership can only depend
on the language of the machine,
not about its particular implementation
like the number of states or
the tape alphabet, and so forth.
Second is that the language can't
be trivial, either including or
excluding every Turing machine.
We'll assume that there's some
machine M1 in the language and
another machine M2 outside the language.
That's the only additional
assumption we need.
Recall that in all the reductions,
we created a machine N,
that either accepts nothing, or
else it has some other behavior,
depending on the behavior
of the input machine M.
Similarly, there are two cases for
Rice's Theorem.
Either the empty set is in P in and
therefore, every machine that doesn't
accept anything is in the language L,
or else the empty set is not in P.
Similarly, there are two cases for
Rice's theorem.
Either the empty set is in P, and
therefore every machine that doesn't
accept anything is in the language L,
or else the empty set is not in P,
and every language that doesn't
accept anything is not in L.
Let's take a look at the case where
the empty set is not in P first.
In that case,
we reduce from the halting problem.
The reduction looks like this, and
just runs M with the end to end input.
And if M halts, then we define N
to act just like this machine M1,
which is in the language.
Thus, N acts like M1 if M halts on the
empty string, and it loops otherwise.
This is exactly what we want.
In the one case, the language
of N is the language of M1, and
hence, N must be in the language.
In the other case,
the language of N is the empty string,
meaning that it's not in L.
And a decider for
L can thus tell the difference and
tell us whether M halted
on the empty string or not.
Now for the other case where
the empty set is in P.
Thus every machine that doesn't accept
any string shouldn't be in the language.
In this case, we just replace M1 by M2
in the definition of the reduction,
so that N behaves like M2,
if M halts on the empty string.
This is fine, but we need to reduce from
the complement of the halting problem.
That is, from the set of descriptions
of Turing machines that loop on
the empty input.
Otherwise, we would end up accepting
when we want to not accept and
vice versa.
All in all then,
we have proved the following theorem.
We'll let L be a subset of strings
representing Turing machines
having two key properties.
First, if M1 and M2 recognize the same
language, that is the same set
of strings, then their descriptions
are both in or out of the language.
This just says that the language only
depends on the behavior of the machine.
And, not on its implementation.
Second, the language can't be trivial.
There must be a machine whose
description is in the language and
a machine whose description
is not in the language.
If these two properties hold,
then the language L is undecidable.